Freunde der Sonne: Eis selber machen
ist nicht so schwer.
Ich habe hier ein Schokoeis mit
gerösteten Haselnüssen und Kirschen
und ein Buttermilch-Orangen-Eis
mit Biskuit und Minze.
Das habe ich gestern ohne Eismaschine
gemacht, aber mit Chemie.
Wie ihr das auch machen könnt,
erfahrt ihr jetzt.
Ih, habe ich
gerade etwa Chemie gesagt? Ja.
Wenn das hier keine Chemie ist,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Probs gehen raus
an "thenicemanoftime".
Das war dein Vorschlag. Vielen Dank
für dieses wunderbare Thema.
Eiscreme hat folgende Bestandteile.
1.: Wasser.
Das Wasser kommt
aus der Milch bzw. aus der Sahne.
Milch und Sahne sind in der Regel
die Basis-Bestandteile von Eiscreme.
2.: Fett.
Es kommt ebenfalls aus der Sahne
bzw. aus anderen
wunderschönen Fettquellen
wie z.B. Butter oder Schoki.
3.: Zucker.
Eis sollte süß schmecken.
Da Süße bei kalten Temperaturen
nicht so stark zum Vorschein kommt
wie bei wärmeren Temperaturen,
brauchen wir hier nicht zu wenig.
Zudem erniedrigt Zucker
den Gefrierpunkt von Wasser.
Dieses Phänomen habe ich euch
im letzten Video erklärt,
wo es um Getränkekühlen ging.
Da könnt ihr es euch
noch mal anschauen.
Wenn man zu wenig Zucker nimmt,
wird das Eis zu hart.
Wenn man zu viel Zucker nimmt,
wird es zu matschig oder flüssig.
4.: Emulgatoren. Wir haben es
beim Eis mit einer Emulsion zu tun.
Zum Beispiel mischen sich
Wasser und Fett nicht so gut.
Da setzen sich die Emulgatoren
an die Grenzfläche
zwischen Wasser und Fett
und stabilisieren die Grenzfläche.
Dasselbe passiert
auch an der Grenzfläche
zwischen Flüssigkeit und Luft.
5.: Fantasie.
Ob ihr Schoko,
Vanille oder Erdbeere mögt,
was auch immer ihr reintun möchtet,
da hilft
Ausprobieren bzw. Experimentieren.
In meinem Fall
habe ich Zartbitterschokolade
mit Butter und Milch geschmolzen.
Hier habe ich noch mal Schokolade.
Ein paar Sauerkirschen.
Hier habe ich Haselnüsse
mit Butter und Honig karamellisiert.
Das ist Eis Nummer 1.
Eis Nummer 2,
da habe ich Buttermilch,
frisch gepresste Orange,
frisch gehobelte Orangenschale,
etwas Minze und etwas Biskuit.
Das Problem bei Eis Nummer 2 ist,
dadurch, dass ich Buttermilch
und Orangensaft habe,
habe ich deutlich
mehr Wasser im Rezept.
Deswegen habe ich beschlossen,
gebräunte Butter dazu zu bringen,
um den Fettgehalt etwas zu erhöhen.
Gebräunte Butter ist, wenn man
Butter in der Pfanne warm macht,
bis sie gerade braun wird.
Hat ein ganz tolles Aroma.
Normalerweise
bräuchte man eine Eismaschine.
Das Prinzip
einer Eismaschine ist simpel:
Sie kühlt und rührt gleichzeitig.
Das Rühren ist deshalb so wichtig,
damit sich keine
größeren Eiskristalle bilden.
Bzw. werden größere Eiskristalle
durch das große Rühren zerschlagen.
Letztendlich gibt es zwei Sachen,
die Eiscreme schön cremig machen.
Das 1.: möglichst
kleine, feine Eiskristalle.
Das 2.:
möglichst viele kleine Luftblasen.
Luft wird viel zu häufig übersehen.
Aber wie beim Backen
spielt Luft auch beim Eis
eine essenzielle Rolle
für die Konsistenz.
Ich habe keine Eismaschine.
Ich könnte eine Eismischung machen
und sie ins Gefrierfach stellen
und über einen Zeitraum
von Stunden immer wieder umrühren.
Aber darauf habe ich keine Lust.
Stattdessen versuche ich
mit den Zutaten zu tricksen.
Ich benutze keine Milch,
sondern gesüßte Kondensmilch.
Der Vorteil:
Sie ist viel dickflüssiger.
Hier ist viel mehr Fett
und viel weniger Wasser drin.
Weniger Wasser heißt: Es können
weniger Eiskristalle gebildet werden.
Je mehr Fett in einem Eis drin ist,
desto cremiger ist es.
Das liegt auch daran,
dass das Fett die Kristallisation
des Wassers stört,
weil Fett und Wasser
ja mischbar sind.
2.: Ich schlage die Sahne vorab.
Wie gesagt: Luftbläschen sind
ein essenzieller Bestandteil von Eis.
Deswegen bringe ich hier
vorab viel Luft rein,
damit ich nachher im Gefrierfach
nicht ständig rühren muss.
Als Emulgator
nimmt man normalerweise Eigelb.
Das mache ich nicht, sonst
müsste man das erst mal erhitzen,
wegen Salmonellen.
Dazu bin ich zu faul.
Stattdessen
kann man Polysaccharide nehmen,
die das Ganze etwas binden.
Das wäre zum Beispiel Stärke,
letztendlich auch Mehl
oder Alginat, Gelatine.
Mir wurde
Johannisbrotkernmehl empfohlen.
Doch gestern im Supermarkt
gab es kein Johannisbrotkernmehl.
Stattdessen stand da Guarkernmehl,
was ebenfalls ein Polysaccharid ist
und ebenfalls bindende Eigenschaften
hat, also verdickende.
Geben wir
dem Guarkernmehl eine Chance.
Aber chemisch gesehen sollte
eigentlich auch Stärke funktionieren.
* leichte, fröhliche Musik *
Freunde der Sonne:
Einen Tag später habe ich Eis.
Ich habe es
über Nacht frieren lassen.
Man kann es sicherlich
auch am selben Tag machen,
wenn man ca.4 Stunden Zeit hat.
Es ist auf jeden Fall sehr cremig.
Ich will mich nicht selbst loben,
aber es ist lecker.
Probiert es aus und schickt mir
Bilder über Facebook und Instagram.
Würde mich sehr freuen.
Danke noch mal an "thenicemanoftime".
Bis nächste Woche, bleibt sicher.
Untertitel:
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk (2017)